i'm nick gillespie of Reason TV and I  want to tell you a tale more terrifying  than Rahm Emanuel in a locker room  shower gaze deeply if you dare since  World War two federal revenue is  averaged right around eighteen percent  of gross domestic product despite all  attempts to jack it up through the roof  or cut it down to size yet federal  spending has grown more sharply than Al  Gore during a full body massage rising  from sixteen percent of GDP in 1952  almost twenty-six percent this year and  spending is projected to be well over  twenty percent of GDP for the  foreseeable the tragic result the  federal government balance sheet is in a  hole deeper than John Boehner Stan